hi everyone
welcome to free code camp and another
vue.js stream if you don't know me my
name is gwen
and i run the faraday academy youtube
channel
that you can check out from the
description below i do
mostly django and vjs content
and a few other things sprinkled in
there
um yeah so if you are a member of this
chat
you can go ahead and comment
or make any suggestions as we're going
along
this is the repo that we'll be working
off of today
it's basically under my github which is
gwen f
uh view nwjs hours tracking and this is
also
linked in the description below
um so it has uh different
yeah all the different information
requirements
uh tech stack so it's going to be
another vue.js application the only
difference between
this and the other apps i've been
building hi anish how are you
it's good to see you
is that it'll be using nwjs which is a
desktop
application framework that uses node.js
and chromium and then i'll be using
um actually not mongodb but i'm going to
look for the same style
of database i think because nwjs has
some
similar options for that hi sassy
how are you it's good to see you again
um yeah and then just bootstrap
for the design library so i don't have
to design it myself
here are the or here is the
schema that i made just a basic
first go at it um
yeah and then i do have some mock-ups
so these are the different pages for
both the mvp and version one
and then i just pick some colors
before the stream
yeah and so this is the road map what i
want to add first
and then what i want to add second and
then i can add more and more things
after that
so this is probably where is it
so hours log will be the first one just
a plain table
and then i'll make it more fancy from
that as well as being able to add
new hours into the log
so this should be a fun project now if
you've used
um electron before
then there are a lot of similarities
because it's
it's i mean it's still building a
desktop app in javascript you can do a
lot of the same things
there are some pros and cons to both of
them
but i'm going to be using like i said
before nwjs
for this project so you can go to
nwjs.io
and the documentation is decent for this
project
and there are some good examples online
especially with vjs that i found
so here's the getting started um
you'll notice there are some differences
let me see if i can find it
yeah so you have this uh so for global
objects
like you have in um when you're
developing in the browser
you have the document object which is
actually also
polyfilled in nwjs
and you have this nw global object so
you can use nw.window
yeah and some other things like that
so um yeah you can do document.body.ad
event
listener so you can use all of your
regular front-end stuff and then you
also have access to
the operating system too so you can
access the
operating system information file system
all kinds of stuff like that
hi techstack glad you're here again
um yes i think that's all i wanted to
say about nwjs
it's an interesting project actually
with a lot of new updates
coming soon um it's also been around a
long time so it's very robust
and i found this or someone showed me
this where
which one is it it's this one
so this uh nw view
cli example so it's it's basically
like um you know when you when you use
the vcli use view create and it sets up
a basic project for you
this is the same thing except it sets up
a basic
nws and view project for us so i'm going
to go ahead and use this boilerplate
here
and i'll post a link to this in the chat
so i'll call it view
nwjs
uh
wait boilerplate
okay and
yeah so there are
some instructions it basically you know
gives you
a boilerplate desktop window these are
all the technologies it uses it
it's not opinionated about a design
framework so we're just going to pull in
bootstrap
and it gives you instructions how to
install packages
start locally that's all the same and
then it gives you a whole bunch of other
commands
that have to do with building desktop
apps for different os's and that kind of
stuff
so i'm going to go ahead and clone this
repository
as a starter so
oh let me copy it
and go to my terminal in this folder so
i'm going to do git
clone nw
if see vcli example except i'm going to
call it
nwjs hour
tracking
okay and now zoom in a little
okay so i have that folder now i'm gonna
go into the folder and
i'm gonna install the dependencies which
will take a minute
so npm install and kind of wait for that
so i know not everyone can chat right
now but for those of you
who can chat how's it going
any comments about desktop apps vue.js
life right now
okay it's not going too slowly that's
good
okay and then right after i install this
i'm going to go ahead and install
bootstrap so i don't have to
stop the server again later
so bootstrap view
let me zoom in again let me go to
the docs
and getting started
actually i should have checked my node
version before i installed everything
there
i'll have to check it after i think i'm
using 12
which is lts because i use mv
nvm so i switch between versions
sometimes
okay so
let's see all right so
npm install i need to install bootstrap
view
and bootstrap it also has view here but
i already have view installed with the
project
so that's it hi tom how are you
it's good to see you again npm install
bootstrap view
and bootstrap so
just waiting for this to finish
installing
and that should just take another second
come on
and then i'll install bootstrap and then
later on
i'm gonna go ahead and make the view
components
and the view application and then later
on i will need to add a database for
this so
not sure i'll get that get to that in
this stream so i might start off next
stream
hopefully adding the database then
i'm doing well i'm happy to still be
streaming
this should be a fun project because
it's a bit larger than
the other projects which were just kind
of one-off one-stream projects
can you brief a little yeah sure i i
will
um brief a little bit more as soon as we
open up
the actual files which i guess i can do
that now
and let me just start installing
what was it bootstrap bootstrap
view and bootstrap
need to install those hi jared
i'm glad you are here so this is this is
kind of cool because jared
is in nwjs and also a view expert
who contributed to the nwjs project
so he knows a lot about this project
so welcome to the chat jared welcome to
free code camp
all right um
okay well while this is waiting let's
take a look at this project
so if you just take a brief oh let me
zoom in
zoom in twice okay so if you just
briefly look at this this looks almost
exactly like
a regular vue.js project
with the exception of probably this file
so it has a server.js file
with express so basic express server
you should be able to do view add
whatever
oh for um vcli plugins
yeah i don't know if i need any plugins
right now
but i'll definitely keep that in mind
okay so the package.json
of course we have all of our regular
view and static files here but i'm going
to go into the package.json right now
and so there's a lot of stuff going on
so you have a lot of the same
objects of course it's a regular
package.json so here are all the scripts
some of them are regular like
testing running testing and linting
all of these build scripts are for
building for
different operating systems so you have
windows
linux is there a mac one
um oh maybe
oh the linux one no build nw that must
be mac
maybe i haven't actually built an into
vgs
um are we at max 720p
so i'm streaming in 720p
and from the preview i get i can see it
in 720p so hopefully you can see it if
you can't see it
in that quality then try changing it in
the youtube settings
because i've had to do that sometimes
when i'm watching someone's stream
and it's low quality you can probably
change it in the youtube settings
hopefully
um yeah so the only commands
that or the only command i'm going to be
running today is actually the start
command
and you can see it runs these two
commands concurrently at the same time
so it runs npm run serve
which is the regular view cli service
command that you get from abuse
ucli
and then this nw
command so it runs the nwjs desktop
server so it can open the actual desktop
app
okay and then some specific things so
there's specific configuration
in here just for desktop applications
and i'm going to go ahead and open the
window
but you can see it has this
metadata about nwjs
so you can choose the height the width
min height width icon and a whole bunch
of other things
for the i think this is the manifest of
nw no for the desktop app that you're
building
so when i open this
clear now let me run
[Music]
npm start
to start the development server and this
should open
the desktop app as well
okay there's a lot of stuff going on
okay now it's running uh
and the port don't need to worry about
the port because
it should have opened here
hmm oh there it goes there it goes
okay so this is the boiler plate and you
can see the window size
actually comes from the size denoted
here
um and then this is also
resizable so i can do it this is built
on chromium
but you don't actually have to have a
chrome browser installed
to run it because it has it built into
nwjs
um yeah and then it just runs it and you
can also
you also have access so this is a
shortcut link
that the
people who made this boilerplate
built in but this is just a link to open
the developer tools so that
i can use developer tools while i'm
building this desktop app
so that's not any different than
electron or any other
desktop application hi bobby welcome to
free code camp
how are you um
okay so okay now i have
the basic page for nwjs
and actually so let me
let me maximize the browser
okay cool it has view dev tools built
into
this template i'm using that's great i
didn't even know that
okay um so there is actually one thing
that i forgot i would have to do here
and if you look at the mock-ups oh wait
it's this way um if you look at the
mock-ups i have
in the repo which if you just joined the
repo is linked in the description below
that i'm going to be working off of and
um need to do that
so you can see it has these different
pages and it has a draw menu here
without links to different pages so i'm
going to need to install view router
to route between the different pages in
the application
and so i will be using the cli plugin
for that
and let me just look it up real quick so
i get the right
name for the package uh
view router
so um
getting let me go to getting started
because
okay oh installation this is the one
let me zoom in one more
okay so it shows via script tag
via npm and view cli so i'll do
view add view router
just peachy awesome so jared says
if you do view ui and add your project
then you oh yeah so vue cli has
a ui interface where i can add
dependencies from there if you haven't
seen it it's really awesome
so i think i'll just do that so let me
do
view ui
because i want to also add
the uh or i want to add state management
as well with vue x
okay so let me see if it opened yeah it
did
so this is the view ui and there's
a server running and serving this ui
interface
and now if i go to plugins
i can see these plugins are the plugins
that are already installed
that came with the boiler plate and
oh no i'm i was like how did this one
get there
uh let me zoom in so actually
these aren't the ones that came with the
boilerplate i have to
um oh wait
i have to zoom out i want to get
there we go i need to open up the right
folder so
let's look at
[Music]
yeah i think view project manager
and projects
import so i have to go into projects
and then i have a lot of stuff in here
so i have nw nws
so uh nwjs hour tracking this is the one
okay and this is my view project so i'm
going to import this folder
okay now i can correctly see
oh click the home button oh yeah that
would have been a shortcut
thanks um okay so
now i can go to plugins
and i can correctly see the plugins that
are installed with this project
and oh great so there are links here
let me zoom in if you can see
there are shortcut links to add these
common plugins i didn't even know they
had this
yeah so add view router
i'm going to click this it's suggesting
it to me
it says official library to support
multiple virtual pages in a single page
app
okay continue
so it's installing view router and then
after this i'm going to install vuex
this is exciting getting to build and
if i actually build this desktop app
it'll be my first one
ever building and distributing to
systems
while this is uh installing actually so
the idea for this app came from my
consulting
because if you watched so on my channel
i have a video about
consulting where i just talk about some
of the things i've learned over the
years
and so this app
it's actually what i do like keep an
hours log
for each different project my next tasks
list
all of this stuff
that i do for myself but i do it all
manually and so someone suggested
that i make a desktop app for it and i
was like oh that's a great idea
um because that would save me so much
time especially
where is it where is it uh where's the
page
especially oh i must not have included
it
oh but there's a a page
for exporting so i can export
as in a csv or i can export an invoice
and i can basically give an hour log to
the client because i always give
the client a breakdown of what i did
on which days and then i also
of course i have to send them an invoice
to get paid so if i could generate those
things
in kind of a simple desktop interface
without
you know all the complicated software
for it out there
this would be kind of a cool thing to
have
um okay so
where is it oh that's probably done now
let me check on that install
oh where is it yeah um
successfully so at the bottom in tiny
tiny words it says successfully invoked
generator for plugin
view cli plugin router okay now let me
add view x then for state management
because there's going to be quite a few
pages and components
yeah and there's no reason to not use
view
x for a multi-page view application
in my opinion anyway maybe some of you
have a different opinion
all right so that's installing
i have bootstrap i have the vcli tools
once this is done installing i'll start
setting up the pages one by one
and the first thing i'll set up
is i guess a top bar
with um with a navigation draw
so let me see what it's called in
bootstrap
if it's called an app bar or a toolbar
does anyone know what it's called i know
the chat legs
like hopefully it's not much more than
five to eight seconds
um okay
let me just look at components oh they
added new components
wonderful um
let's see navbar that makes sense
oh yeah right it's bootstrap's nav nav
bar thing
let's see
navs navigation is available in
bootstrap
uh share general markup and styles from
the base b
nav class to the active and disabled
states okay
so this is a basic nav bar
and you can change the appearance of the
links if i want tabs i will want tabs
for something later on
but not yet
so the only thing i really want in the
nav bar
or the two things is really a link oh no
no
it's a button to open the draw menu and
then
i want the logo or the title the name of
the app basically
and that's it
okay so i think i can work with this
oh pills so pills will make it look
like a button
um no because that will make whichever
one's active look like a button
so yeah i'll probably just copy the
basic one
for this
okay yeah there's
a lot of stuff here okay i'm gonna get
rid of that
and now let me check on the install
okay that's installed let me refresh
this page
because it's not showing those two new
yeah so once i've refreshed
it's now showing the router plugin
and view x
can we try sidebar it says new
uh yeah let me look at that sidebar
what's the difference between a sidebar
and a draw menu
let's see toggle sidebar
oh cool that looks nice actually
i like that okay
that's what i want
um so using sidebar
and using nav nav bar
so let me look at navbar see what
examples they have
yeah i'm going to copy this basic navbar
example then
and first let me
run the app again and i'm gonna stop
this server for the view ui that i
started
yeah fancy um
let's see
uh what do i want to do
oh yeah i keep wanting to type in python
here because i've been running so many
django commands
i want to do npm start
okay dev server spinning up again
this will open the desktop app again
and oh this was an accident
so oh oops
oh i'm gonna have to um fix
this i think install or adding those
view cli plugins messed it up because
those are made for regular view projects
and they might have intrusively changed
some things
that they weren't supposed to change in
nwjs
so maybe i should have installed them
manually i don't know okay so i'll fix
that in a second
i did make a mistake here and that is i
think
bootstrap and at least view router and
view x
should have been installed
in dev dependencies so
i think i messed that up but i can
always move that over later
so i'm not too worried about that right
now
okay because once it builds i don't need
those packages so i don't need to ship
useless packages
okay so in source let me see
what what these things did
yep so uh what did this do
okay so it changed my app dot
view file which i don't think this is a
big deal here i think the main
issue is that
it
changed this and for some reason the app
is erroring
here okay
and then what else did it set up so it
set up a store
this is fine set up the index.router
file
um that should also be good although i
don't need all of these routes
so i'm going to change the routes so
let's see why isn't this island disable
oh yeah that's the iceland so
creating a new view object render
rendering the app so i don't see why
um what was the error message
oh okay i'll show you the error message
why
this would have a problem with it let me
see
so oh it's saying
oh okay it's saying it can't resolve
this i see
assets asset.logo.png it's because there
isn't one
i'm pretty sure yeah because in this
project
it's expecting this to be a normal view
project which already has an
assets slash logo.png but this one
doesn't
so i'm gonna see uh
where it's trying to pull that in okay
so it's in home.view it's trying to
display this logo.png
yeah it does look okay um
so what was it nw
what was the file name let's see yeah
nw.png
so yeah now it works sweet and i have my
view router set up
so it works just like a normal view
router
okay cool um so let me open the
developer tools for later so i have it
oh yeah still has that error
so it makes sense to rename them that
should be fixed in the boiler plate
to avoid this bug for others yeah
so it's good it's good i'm testing out
this boiler plate for everyone
all right so now i have my
router let me add that top nav in the
sidebar now
so in bootstrap
i'm in nav bar so i'm going to copy this
nav bar
and then get rid of most of the stuff
inside
okay so nav bar
let me also delete some of the extra
stuff so let me delete this about page
and then i have to delete it from router
2.
so let me delete
okay
where is it uh let me also delete
so the home page uh
okay i'll leave that alone for right now
so in this app.view this is where
i'm gonna delete um
or i'll add this above real quick so i
have the
um oops
this i pasted the nav bar in
and i need to indent
this and
now i need to
let's see i need to get rid of
all of these items i think what is
navbar collapse
oh yeah so that is
um drop down item i don't think i need
navbar collapse
so let me get rid of that then
just start from scratch with that
okay so let's see how this looks
okay so i just have a basic nav bar
there oh am i
i'm not importing the css
that's what i'm not doing hi
in namdee how are you
that's a that's a cool name um
welcome to free code camp
so uh oh if you don't know i'm building
a desktop app with uh nwjs and vue the
link is in the description below
so um now i have the navbar i'm not
importing the bootstrap css or i must
not be because it's not displaying
anything so
let me stop what i'm doing real quick go
back to getting started
and
um where is it
okay i need to scroll down
okay using module bundlers
in all my installs i forgot to actually
set up bootstrap so
i'm going to have to put this in my
main.js file
so let me go to that main.js file
and
well okay so absolute imports
should go first and then
i have relative imports and then
i can put this here
okay so now i'm registering this and i
still need the css links
oh no it didn't like that
okay oh view imported twice that's why
thanks okay so
uh oh i guess i need the css here
then because those are absolute
imports or uh library imports
what i mean okay
so um
css yeah so i think that's it
oh also oh cool that looks nice this nav
bar
um also i would like
um
what was i going to say i can't remember
what i was going to say but i'll i'll
remember it in a minute
so let me add that option to open the
menu
from the nav bar from bootstrap
so in components where's that new
sidebar
okay it's a fixed position
toggleable slide out box which can be
used for navigation menus details
okay
so i'll copy the basic sidebar then
and i'll also copy the button
uh which toggles oh i didn't know in the
docs now you can double click to edit
oh that's pretty cool
um yeah bootstrap
docs are good so let me go to
um where is it oh yeah in my
app.js file so in app.js
i'll go here
and put the sidebar
and now this button for toggle sidebar
i'm going to put
inside of v navbar
toggles okay so i don't want that so let
me put
oh wait undo i think i have to yeah
oh it's because i just
undid that there we go
let's see how that looks
okay so toggle sidebar and i want to
switch these two
around i think
and i'm going to rename this to
menu
that's pretty cool it has a prop to
toggle the sidebar from the button
um and the sidebar one
okay so it's referencing the id here so
i guess i'll call this
sidebar not sidebar one because there's
no other sidebar
okay so that should still work
yeah um the menu
oh yeah and then i was gonna switch
these around so
oh that's that's pretty ugly oh because
uh
the title must be giving some margin
right
so i can just add some margin to
this button then so i can add a class
and use a margin shorthand from
bootstrap which i think
is margin margin right
and i'll say 4 to push it out a little
bit
which is something like 16 pixels
bootstrap doesn't do it
exactly in increments of four pixels for
these numbers so
let's see yeah i think that looks okay
um other docs using
view live edit and see it
update the demo in real time yeah it's
using
uh something so
let's see i can get rid of shadow
and now there's no elevation on the
sidebar yeah so
i guess that's v live i don't know but
it's updating live
for bootstrap that's pretty cool
okay um so now i have the menu open
now i need to put stuff in the sidebar
that was really
low effort like nice to use
um so i'm gonna
put that down here and
get rid of the paragraph in the sidebar
oh there's a title here so what should i
call the title
i guess i'll call it menu i could do
username or with an avatar or something
i don't know
um or main menu
okay and this so this div is just
providing some spacing inside so
padding on the x-axis
of three um and then padding
on the y-axis of two i'll leave that
spacing
div there and then i'm going to add
these router links inside and see how
they look
and i might want to put these in a list
i don't know how what would look best in
bootstrap
commit
oh this is awful um yeah that was a bad
idea
so i'm going to put these in a list view
in a bootstrap list so
let me see first if they have an example
here
of shadow borders
with padding disable scope header
footer backdrop
okay
yeah i think it's getting all right so
it has the full
api details but i'm going to look for a
list here
so list group
and let me see all right so that's a
list group
and oh it can show active items
to indicate a selection so
it's not exactly what i want or maybe
i'm just used to the material
uh design from beautify all the time
or if you prefer button elements over
links see the button prop okay so you
can
make these into buttons instead of
list links i guess
um colors badges
okay um yeah i think unless someone
knows of something better let me look
for list
actionable list group items
yeah so this is what i want i mean the
style can always be
changed later it's not a big deal so i'm
going to copy this
list group
and put it inside the draw
okay and now so inside of each
list group item
i'm gonna have
um yeah i'm gonna have the view router
link
so oh let me get rid of it
add it here and then
okay that works i can change the
color and underline state i guess and
then
and i'll just get rid of about here so i
can just copy this link
um oh okay so there's actually an href
from here
and then there's a router link inside so
actually oh wait um i don't need
the router link inside
which will stop the need for extra
styling which is good
so i'll just put a forward slash here
and have home
that looks pretty good the home link
so let me
what's next so i guess i can add all of
these links
that i have in the mock-ups down here
let's see
oh my other mock-up i see where it is
i'm
it's not displaying so i must have
spelled it wrong in the readme
okay um
let's see add
[Music]
entry
um yeah so i need a button at the top
actually and then i need these four
links
and then a horizontal line
so there might actually be a bootstrap
component for this horizontal line
so let me see hours log projects
exports and settings
so hours
log
okay then
projects and then
exports and
oh wait uh
settings
all right so now i have the menu here
and um
what else i guess i don't need a
horizontal line
unless i could make these two different
list groups actually so i could
what i could do is actually
here close that list group and then make
another
b oh wait b list
group
yeah and then just
very quickly i can add a class of margin
top
of two give it a little bit of spacing
yeah that's okay for now uh class
drop down divider okay
oh jared wants to post a link so let me
show the link
get bootstrap docs components dropdowns
dividers
cool thank you um oh get out of that
let me divider
oh i'm looking i'm looking in view
router for dividers let me go to
uh drop down
these are all in drop downs
and i can't scroll down so
they don't have a divider component but
since i'm updating bootstrap
like you mentioned i can
oh cool because i'm getting the chat
directly through youtube this time so
it's letting me copy paste
or copy from the chat okay so let me
copy this divider then
and see how it looks um in between these
two list groups
i'll paste that divider
nice so i have the two different list
groups
and then i have a divider and then i
guess i can get rid
of this margin class because it looks
like
it's the same space on either side of
the divider either way
okay good so now i have
a menu so now i need to make this main
home page and
let's see oh yeah
let me go to the mock-up and look at the
main page
so it's basically a table of all
the hour logs that looks fine
yeah i think it looks it looks fine to
me
i mean you're the you're a design expert
so
and we can always change something later
okay so hours log
um oh yeah so i need a bootstrap table
here
the tabs i'm going to worry about these
tabs later so for right now
i'm going to have a title a button and
a table with four columns so let me just
work on that
and okay so i have app.view
and then this router view
is displayed and actually i'm going to
need to use the
view
what is it called the grid system not
the view grid system but the bootstrap
grid system
so let me find which component i'm going
to use
right now i only have this one component
which is home
and actually i'm going to change this
to hours
log um
and the component will be hours log
so
hours long
hours log okay and now i need to
actually rename this component to
hours log oh wait
uh hours log and
i'll delete the hello world i'll delete
this image
i'll give it a class of hours log
page um in case i want to
name space my sas later
oh is it slog did i put slog
hours log
yeah it's hours long i don't think i
misspelled it anywhere
our slog okay
so i'll get rid of the hello world
component
the name here should be hours log
okay how is everyone else everyone else
is kind of quiet in the chat
how do you think it's going so far
so i have the hours log page and
i need i need a title first
and actually here so let me go ahead and
look at the bootstrap grid system
because
i'm going to need to implement that so
let me look for
grid
uh layout and grid system so
okay so it's b container b row and b
column which is same thing as
usual all right so
i'm going to change this div into b
container actually
and then i'll do b
container and then
inside of that i'll do a b row
and then i'll do a b column here
so uh b column
your legs are shaking and excitement
great
okay so
um i don't know how exciting the mvp is
but
it's definitely exciting if i can get
this app working
so
let's see
um b-row here's here's column
which i want so how do i
okay so i can do offset equals or offset
dash small
and then okay so the props are small
medium large extra large normal
so into b column i want the table
centered on the page so i guess for
small
oops for small i'll do
let me try eight columns and then
offset small is
two columns because there's a total of
12 columns
and then i'll put the header in here
so i'll put actually
i want the header and
let's see so this column will contain
everything on the page
and then inside of this column i'm
actually going to do
this is the thing about component
libraries there's so much nesting
so i'm going to do another b column
because i want the header
inside of a b column
and now i'll put an h1 in here
and i think this is how i want it unless
i just want to do
some flexbox in here but
so let me give this a title of hours log
close that
and then close the column and then i
want another column here
which will be for the button
for this add entry button
so i think the button
oh let me add the column first so b
column and then i think
button in bootstrap will be be
btn and then
that will be add
what is it i forgot what it was already
add entry
add entry
okay and then close the button close the
column
close the row and i think that's it
yeah and then i'll add another rule with
the table in it
yeah that's pretty good the only other
thing is on this
nested row here i want to add a margin
top so it's not pushed up against the
very top of the page
so class equals margin
top of five
yeah that looks pretty good and
what else oh yeah that button should
also have a color
so i think i'm gonna put
is it color or there was another keyword
i can't remember what it is
for primary nope
that doesn't work so let me look for
button in here
or i can just click on button
oh variant that was it yeah thank you
anish
it's variant uh variant
okay wow that's bright um
that's fine so they can add entry
and now i'm gonna put a table below this
so it's been exactly one hour
and we already have a desktop app i'm
pretty happy with this
and we have another almost an hour to go
so um
let's see oh yeah table let me get a
table component
i need some water
all right need a bootstrap table
oh wow do they have table light and
table simple
i wonder what those are
let me look table okay so it's all under
table
so for displaying tabular data b table
sports pagination filtering sorting
custom rendering various styling options
events
and asynchronous data yeah the hour went
back
one by fast you know even when i've done
like four hour streams they just seem to
fly by
like nothing well especially now that
people chat when
my very first couple live streams where
it was just me talking to myself
they felt like they took a long time
so supports pagination filtering sorting
custom rendering various styling options
events extinct
data a lot of stuff for simple display
of tabular data without all the fancy
features bootstrap u
provides two lightweight alternative
components
b table light and b table simple
um so i'm not going to use those but
that's good to know about because
i do want this to be
filterable sortable and support
infinite scroll which is
pagination
so i'm gonna use a basic b
table and i guess i'll start off with
just the most basic variety
um okay so so it's not passing in the
headers separately
so i guess it's getting the header items
or it must be getting them from
the keys in the objects
so let me
um okay so let me make a new row here
b row and
inside of it put a b column
even though it's full width i want it to
match up with any spacing
with the above rows and columns
okay oops
so b o b row
and then i think that's right and now
let me
paste the table inside and let me copy
the items too actually
so let me get this
um actually i don't think i have any of
this so
oh no i do so let me just get the
data then okay so
i have components and
now i have the items on the table nice
so i have a table
of items um
yeah it's not the columns that i want
though so let me update the columns
so i need project name i need date start
and end okay
so let me delete all these extra rows
for right now
and just update this one so
project and then underscore name
because i guess that's how you denote
for the column
like how many words you want you put
underscores in the middle even though
javascript generally doesn't use
underscores so what should i call
uh i'll just call this
company one and then
um and then date
oh date
and i'll say may 12
2020 and then i'll do
start time
which is
i don't know uh start time
you now i'll do uh should i do 24 hour
clock
um
let me do seven oh seven
a.m yeah
sorry i'm using the 12-hour clock
because i'm from america
and it's just easier for me so maybe
that will be an
option in settings later so um
let me do 11
am
not a fan or returns
oh you're not a fan of returns what does
that mean
i don't know what that means
um
let's see oh cool awesome
so now i have my first log entry here
and just
um to make this a little bit better i'm
going to put some spacing in between
the header and the table so
let's see um since i already have a
class here i'm gonna add it here
so i'll do margin bottom
and try four yeah that adds some good
spacing
between the table and then later on
there will be tabs here so you can see
the table view or a list view that will
show
the logs
oh you're saying i'm not a fan of
returns because i put all my code on one
line
no i like returns um actually this
should
all right i'll do this i'll i'll do this
nicely real quick
this should have returns in it
okay everyone's happy now
that's better okay and now i want to
create a second page now that i have
hours log let me hook up the projects
page
and so the projects page
actually i need an ad entry page too but
let me just hook up the projects page
real quick so i have the second
route and this will have a drop down
of all the projects um
and then oh i need a button here too
actually so i need a button here for add
a project
because the projects are what you're
going to associate your hours with so
when you log new hours you need to
associate it
with a project
yeah so and we're gonna have that
association in the database
as you can see um so i have a projects
table or i will have a projects table
or collection or whatever it's gonna be
um
and then where is the oh time entry
and then i'll have time entries um
and then yeah solve time entries and
then
i was thinking about making separate log
entries although if it's no sequel then
i probably won't make these separate
tables
but yeah i'm going to figure out
if it's sql or nosql probably for the
next stream
so anyway um
and if you watch my video on consulting
then you'll know why i have logs of what
i did every day
because when we export the
the documents for a client to see it
will have
log entries of the time you worked on
the day and also
bullet points of like all the different
things you did that day
and what you accomplished okay so
projects so
i need the title i need to add new
project button and then i need this
drop down here so let me create a new
view
because it's a separate page so i'll
call this
projects dot view
i keep hitting escape because i'm so
used to using vim
so then it deletes the file that i'm
trying to make okay projects dot view
enter and let me start off with
a template and let me go to hours log
and steal some of this stuff here so
um yeah let me steal all of this
actually
everything and then i'll delete the
table basically so
yank that and
paste it here
and then delete this table
okay and now let me hook this into the
actually let me change
the title real quick so projects
and add
new project
all right and now let me hook this into
the router
so i'll make a new um
what's oh okay so let me make a new
route the path will be
project so projects
the component will be projects and the
name will be
projects okay and
i'll duplicate this
projects
projects
okay and now i need to make a link and
actually i'm gonna
put the forward slash i don't know if i
need it
but just to match up with this one
unless i shouldn't put it there i can't
remember what
what i did in all my other view routers
okay so um oh yeah
in my navigation
let me do projects
and now if i go to projects
it doesn't do anything okay
let me refresh this
does it refresh doesn't refresh
projects why doesn't it
must be with the routing okay yes pass
starts with forward slash okay so it's
not routing correctly
and i wonder if that's
um because i should be using
the view router 2 for these view router
routes
instead of an href
i don't think
is it the order
oh because it's matching i see what
you're saying
because it's matching this route before
it ever gets to this route i could
try changing the order here let me try
all right let me try going to projects
nope it's not the order for some reason
it is refreshing because the council
the console is refreshing so
i guess it's a problem i would say
that it's a problem with
with the href instead of using two
so it's not using view router
yeah so i think i'll have to do that
because if i do
let's say
uh it shouldn't be the order all my
routes start with forward slash
yeah i thought so okay so i'm gonna
change it back then
real quick
okay so try that idea now
now let me do uh
[Music]
oh it's router link uh router link
two equals uh slash
projects and then
close the router link and let me get rid
of
um the href here
although now it's just gonna have the
text as a link instead of the whole
button
so yeah i have to click on the text
which stinks
oh try putting oh because it's not
history mode
that's right so my router is not set up
in history mode
so maybe if i put um
the hashtag not the hashtag the
pound sign first
okay let me try that
yeah because i think that's probably why
it's refreshing
all right so let me go back to
yeah it's not going anywhere in here too
so let me do this
as well
um okay so let me go
here now yeah that works cool so now
it's looking
for the hash router
instead of the history router
okay so now i have add a new project
and i'll also have a filterable search
search searchable drop down
um so let me add that
and it would be called
drop down i guess or it would prob it
would be a select
actually
yeah because these are just drop down
with links that's not what i want at all
so let me do uh jared says i would just
use view route of programmatically
routing and look for the route names
instead of paths
um yeah i could do that
i'm okay with how it is now
yeah that's what i'm doing but this
isn't just a two-hour project so
i'm going to be hopefully working on
this the next
couple weeks making this actual work the
only thing i'm not going to do
on one of these streams is actually
building this app for different os's
because
i guess it doesn't say it here but
apparently it takes forever to build one
of these desktop apps so i'm gonna have
to do that
off stream but all the other setup i
should be doing
on stream uh where will you be working
on it at i'll be i'll be doing all of
the work for this project on these free
code camp streams on fridays
so friday morning 10 to 12
is my slot that i've been given
so yeah
form select this is what i want
okay so these are drop down selects that
i want
and let's see what components
um bootstrap has for this because i
really want
the user to be able to start typing and
search for an item and eventually i'll
have to be making api
calls based off their search so i don't
pull in
oh no no this is a desktop app what am i
talking about
uh yeah this should be fine but i still
want them to be able to type in and
search
oh fc fcc free code cam
i'm not going to be doing it on my
twitch account
um please select some
item value in single mode yeah
okay that's multiple select
don't want that don't want that
yeah so i don't think bootstrap has it
let me see if it has
search no there's no search
um i could look at their api for this
component
properties properties they don't have
any events oh they do
so input change so i'll have i'll
be listening for an on change event
because i'll load the project that they
choose based off of that
and that's going to also route them to
the next page with a breadcrumb to go
back
okay so those are properties
um and the properties
yeah they don't have any typing
in so i could just add
i could add that at another library for
that
let's see um view
select component i can't remember what i
added last time
but there's got to be at least several
of these components
okay view select is a feature reach
feature feature rich
drop down component
all right that looks nice
and you can start typing so i could
start typing
nigeria and select it
cool and then it has it's clearable
by default or an option for it anyway
okay this seems to be good
the last relate date is in july oh let
me zoom in
let me take a look at their github real
quick
view select
yeah looks looks fine to me
so i'm gonna go ahead and go with this
and go to installation
installation my computer is running
really hot right now
okay so i need to install it and then
register it as a component
so let me go and stop my server
clear
alright so that's installing
and now while that's installing
oh it closed my windows for me i didn't
realize it would do that
um so let me import
these and then the component doesn't
include any css so
i can import that separately
or i can import the scss so that's one
thing i really should have
set up i guess is scss i guess i can set
it up later
but it would be nice to have like a sass
folder for when i want to customize the
styles
okay so let me go to
[Music]
main.js and after bootstrap
i'll import the view select
and then oh no
this goes here uh yeah
that goes there and let me
delete that and now i need to import the
css
so i'll import that
and um
yeah put that
oh wait there
okay so now it has the css
yeah that's fine um installation
uh drop down options
okay so now that i've registered the
component i can use it
as a v select and then pass it
props i guess so the props would make it
oh it's searchable without me passing in
any extra pops that's nice
all right so let me close main.js
close that i can close this
and i'm just working out of projects now
and i'm going to put that v select
inside of here
so oh yeah let me run the server first
so
i need to start that server again so
npm start
all right building webpack is going okay
it's done now it'll open there
and let me get
so i v select options
so i could just pass an array or i can
pass
in array of objects which is what i want
to do for options
because i want the value to be different
from the label
basically yeah
it is but after initial build it's okay
and
soon we'll have i guess better options
to webpack or
advanced webpack that builds faster i
don't know
or maybe better computers that build
webpack faster maybe it's my computer
that's slow
yeah vi vite is exciting
um let's see view three should be out
next month and then i guess vite
or vite version one should be out in a
couple months i think
am i right all right so
i'm gonna get
rid of that make it self-closing and
then
also just so
i get my returns in there so let me
put this on multiple lines
and see how that looks go to menu
projects
awesome
and it works out of the box it doesn't
quite match the bootstrap styling but
it's pretty close
and i'm not too worried about it um
so basically i'll have a list of the
projects here
once i have projects and then
they'll display and i'll be able to
search for them
and actually because i have view x i can
go ahead and be saving things in view x
even before i get a database
oh you're saying because it's mac it's
slow no this computer is like five years
old
and i've been running it like all day
every day
for the last five years um
it keeps the desk nice and toasty i
think it actually makes this room hot
with all
the lighting and the mac and everything
this room
gets like 10 degrees hotter while i'm
streaming
okay so i'm going to leave this page as
it is for now
and exports and settings pages i guess
i'll have to work on those
next stream or if i get time later but i
do want to make this ad
entry page um
oh yeah and i wanted to have a button at
the top here
to as a shortcut but i guess if this is
the default page anyway maybe i don't
want the button
i don't know it's only a few pages in
the app
um yeah but i am gonna get a new mac
hopefully
soon i picked out all my specs but
they're just so expensive i'm just
waiting as long as possible
i have a linux computer that works great
for everything but i don't stream
from it and i don't have my client
software on it either so i kind of work
on
work on the side with that
okay so ad entry i need to make
i guess a time entry page
and let's see so in views
i'll make new file should i call it time
entry
time entry dot view and this will have a
template too
and i'll do the same
kind of things v container
v row
v column
then i won't have a second column here
so i think i'll just do h1
and then new
time entry
uh wait until apple silicone comes out
huh yeah that
they just really want computers to be
phones yeah i don't know
i don't know about that i'm just what
i'm happy about is that they fixed that
keyboard
and now they're no longer using the
butterfly keyboards they have the magic
keyboard
which is supposed to be much better
so because the butterfly keyboard my
friends who have it most of them
broke keys or a trouble and i just
didn't like typing on it at all
so i'm i'm really happy they fixed that
after a couple years but they fixed it
the new mac also has a physical escape
key
i don't want to be talking too much
about mac but i think that was a better
option to add that back instead of just
a
bar whatever the
screen bar thing okay so now i have
add new time entry this will be where
the form is
um okay now i need to make this page
routable
so in my routes i'm gonna
say okay so i have hours log so actually
after hours log
i'm gonna do
i don't know add
time entry
because i'll have an ad log entry too
later
so
uh time entry component
and
time entry imported from
uh time entry
uh yeah i'm happy with i've gotten yes
using vm without sp
physical escape key yeah that's that was
a big thing that i didn't like
because i use the escape key all the
time and actually on
so at my desk here when i'm not
streaming i use um
programmable keyboard so i have my
escape key right at my pinky finger so i
can just hit escape all the time it's
right next to there
instead of being way up in the corner
which isn't ideal for vim users
uh a complaint
terminal what's a complaint terminal
windows has a complaint terminal to
complain to windows about things you
don't like about it
yeah i used windows for years before i
used mac
um let's see
i just think for development linux and
mac are easier and mac
is the one that has a lot of programs
working for it but
we'll see how windows turns out with
their new adoption of linux i'm excited
about that
okay so time entry i need a form here
let me go grab a bootstrap form
form oh i'm not in the right place
let me go here bootstrap form
okay bootstrap form component and helper
components that optionally support
inline form styles
okay so here's the basic form i'm just
going to copy it because it looks
fine to me form
data results okay
oh cool it has already has an on reset
method as well so
let me
uh take the whole form
and paste it in here then i'll just
get rid of the stuff that
i don't want
okay b form so i need to indent that
yeah i think that's good um
yeah that looks good and now
i might need do i need data in here
oh i also need to make a route for the
card
um class form oh this is form data the
form data results okay
so and these are the v
bound variables in
the data method okay food so that must
be some kind of a drop down
show equals true i don't need show and
hide so i'm going to get rid of that
be if oops what did i do um
let me go to here
okay so on reset on submit i'll have to
make those methods
and then form group why do form groups
only have one input
or i guess if you're doing things on the
same line
uh can we have the new entry form on a
modal box
i want i want it on a separate page
um i think yeah i don't always like
forms and modals although sometimes
it's okay i guess if i was doing it in a
table
no even then i don't know um
anyone else have an opinion about
putting the form in a modal
uh can we have a new entry what's nice
about nwjs though
is that you can write all of your code
once and it will run on windows linux
and
osx yes that is the nice thing
modals are just asking for trouble
thanks
asking for trouble
okay so let me get rid of some of these
extra inputs
and check boxes i can leave those okay
i'm
going gonna need to make a script tag
here so i can
remodel my elements so i need data
and return an object
and then
so form data and then i'll need to
remodel all of my elements inside of
here
and then i need two methods as well so
let me go ahead and create those methods
on a methods object
i need on submit which is a method
yep and what's the other one
oh it's called on reset
so on reset to reset the form
okay
avoid modals whenever possible
yeah i hear that from designers all the
time
avoid modals or yeah
basically don't use modals for forms
just for displaying information
um okay
so
let's see
um what was i doing oh yeah let me make
it the page routable so when i click add
entry it should route to this time entry
page
um so i need to put that on the hours
log
this add entry so
split up the lines here and then
i'll add the add click at the end so
when they click on this add entry button
it should route them
so i think i can do router.push
because because i have the router object
available to me
in the component so if i do dot push and
then push the route that i want
which is um
i think from here i can do name right so
i can say
just denote the name of the route that i
want
um which is
time entry so
i can do name time entry
and then from time entry
i'm not sure if view router will break
but i just want to add the component
name here
so it matches up time
entry okay
that's good so
uh yeah what just happened there
okay
uh oh yeah all of this stuff is not
defined i need to clean up my form
uh does that have something to do with
accessibility okay
you are all talking about accessibility
of modals
so i'm gonna let that happen
and type
reset um okay these are check
boxes so let me see what items i need
in this form in the first place and put
those items in the form
and let me go to time entry
um so
eventually i'd like these
to be automatic like there to be a timer
in the app
to start and stop like a little window
that pops up in the corner of your
desktop where you can start and stop
your time
but for right now it's manual entry so
they're going to have to
input a start time and put a stop time
and then i want
like a text field of any notes
that they have and then there's going to
be a foreign key
relating a project to the time entry
later but not right now
so i basically need start stop and notes
so i can get rid of the check boxes let
me get rid of these
um i can also get rid of this
uh these
drop down so now i just have one input
which
is going to be actually i need a date
input so let me look that up
okay oh cool so it's displaying now i
do need this i forgot to do oh no i have
a container
um this is centered for some reason
that text okay so i'm going to do
um
let's see okay so this isn't all in one
i need to add another
v row and then nest all these components
so that i can have a v
column here small
i will do 6 6 columns wide
and then offset small
will be 12 columns wide
and then all of this stuff
will be nested inside
and all of that
so container okay so i'm going to indent
these ones
and it's going to be oops
command okay and then here
i'm going to uh wait
didn't like that close the column and
then close that row
okay and now it should be more centered
is it
is it just catching up now or did i do
something wrong
because i have the rows inside of this
column now
which should be six columns wide on
small
and oh it's offset is 12 columns that's
weird
offset is three columns
okay offset small
yeah so i'm not sure why this isn't
working right now
i can compare it to my other component
so i have
oh this is so dumb okay so
i'm in beautify mode still and when you
use the beautified
design library it um
has v dash for everything so let me see
if i can
do b dash and
yeah shouldn't have anything else so let
me replace this with b
dash and change that
okay now okay
now it works properly that's much better
i don't know if anyone said that no
everyone's kind of talking about
modals and accessibility
in the app okay
so that's just okay for right now
i don't have a lot of time so i'm gonna
just finish
adding the form inputs and
let me look for the date
date times here so date
form date picker that looks promising
b form date picker
okay so it picks a date
and then what about the time though
is there a time picker
uh some some ui libraries have it where
you can have them both in one so you can
choose the date
and then you and then it brings up
another box where you can choose the
time
um hmm
i wonder if you can default to the
current date
button only mode okay i don't want that
um so let me look real quick at a time
picker
and then see how i want to
do this time selection widget
okay so they are completely separate
uh this is interesting
what is this never seen something like
this before
if you need a time picker as a custom
form control use the okay this is what i
want then
the b form time picker
oh and then it pops up here so it's the
same
ui which is okay i guess
and then can you type in here can i type
oh no i type here right this is weird
uh okay and then i guess they probably
have
oh wow a lot of options
i guess they probably have our 12 okay
so this toggles 24 hour versus 12 hour
so that's good does anyone else think
this time picker looks a little weird
um but i'll go ahead and use it for now
that's fine so let me go to the most
basic example
oh that's disable no it's not disabled
um yeah let me get the date picker and
time picker
and
expand this
um so
i'm actually going to get rid of this
and inside here i'll put
the time picker and
i'll make that self-closing
and then put it on multiple rows
okay so v model will be
wait uh form data
dot start time
or i should put start i guess because
there's start and end for times
and then there is
um just one date
because it won't go over into the next
date so
everything is separated by which day you
worked on
and yeah so if you need to go into the
next day i guess it's going to
not go over or should i like if you work
from 11 p.m
until 2 a.m should i have two different
dates for that
maybe i should if people want to work
wonky hours that should be up to them
your name so okay um so here
i need to put start date
and
end date
okay so now i need to add that date time
form date picker
ujs date object okay
so jared's recommending view to date
picker let me take a look at that
um view to date
picker
view to date picker on npm
let me go through mpm so i can find the
official github
for the project we have about 10 minutes
left
how's everyone doing what did you think
about the desktop app today
date picker oh this is interesting
i can do date ranges i like that
internationalization let me take a look
so home page
which is the repository but let me go
there
it's running a little bit slow all right
so view to date picker
so this doesn't do times but i can get
the date range
which is good
there are i guess themes for it
the props are documented that's good
uh okay
this is nice all right
yes it does click the demo oh what demo
is it this
yeah must be this
let's see oh it has time too
oh i like i like this better than
the bootstrap one with the arrows
select week
week 28 okay select
date
select month this is nice
select year i might use this for other
things in the app too
select date time
okay date time is what i want then
select date time because i can select
the date
and the time for both the start and the
end that's perfect
thanks jared that's a good idea oh this
isn't zoomed in so i don't know if you
can see it but
um okay and then i also have
oh okay so this is date time range
so let me pick a
date and then
an end date oh and then it says a time
i don't know if i want these both in the
same one
okay but it's cool it lets you do the
hours seconds
everything hours minutes seconds
um do i want these all in one or do i
want
two different boxes one for start and
one for end
okay so let me install this library for
starters
uh let's see
install save view to date picker okay
i'm gonna have to stop the server again
all right so
npm install view to date picker
we have a couple minutes left so i'll
have to pick back up on this
uh next time
we do a form for date and a form for
time the news have computed
to combine them into one date object
i think i'm going to do them two
separate ones so
i'll store the i want the date and the
time together
but i want i don't want the start date
and the end date
to be in the same form
basically oh i think
uh youtube started lagging a little bit
more
toward the end so that must be
about 20 seconds behind
or 15 seconds maybe i don't know
okay so
i have nwjs hour tracking
and now uh oh yeah let me start the
server again so npm start
i have that installed and i can start
setting it up so
i need to import the date picker
register it as a component and i can
just do this
locally i guess it doesn't matter i can
always do it
globally as well
okay
there's my window
add entry
go to the add entry page and yeah
now that i look at this again i really
don't like this interface because
i can't even type in here so i have to
just keep clicking 30 times
or click and hold yeah
it's okay but i think it needs some
improvement so i'm gonna get rid of
these then
these bootstrap
form form picker time picker whatever
get rid of those oh input group
ids i shouldn't have the same ids
multiple times
label 4
um yeah i don't have these yet
but i will and
now let me do
uh date picker i need the css where
okay import date picker import date
picker
css so i'm going to do these globally so
let me go to my main.js file
and
import the date picker
okay and now i need to do view dot use
so let's see
um oh after
so view dot
is it oh it's registering component yeah
view dot component
and then i guess
i can what is it date dash picker
yeah so it's the same thing so date
dash picker and then
so it's registered as date dash picker
and now i need to pass in
a component which is date picker
okay so now i have it registered here as
date picker and i can go to
my form and i should be able to use it
here
oh yeah oh no i got the css that's good
good good
so now i can use
this so let me just grab one let me grab
the date time
one and paste it here
and okay let me make this self closing
again
so
i'll do that oh yeah and v model so i'll
do
form data dot
start date
okay cool
um it's not working because it's not
remodeling to anything but
the drop down works that's good so let
me quickly add this to the
to the end one
and okay that's good
oh what happened what happened
end date uh
okay so hour log ad entry something's
wrong where is
the console you can just do
oh my shortcut hotkey didn't work so let
me inspect
don't forget to plug your youtube twitch
oh yeah
uh check out my youtube channel
uh faraday academy i'm also faraday
academy on twitch
academy oh misspelled v
model did i
uh where is v model
start date v model
um i don't think i misspelled v
model is this on twitch
no no it's not this particular stream
isn't
so twitch doesn't let me stream as a
twitch affiliate i can't stream on two
platforms at the same time
um but that's complicated anyway so
but i do all of my coding live streams
on my
faraday academy twitch channel
no yeah so
um let me just see what the error is
real quick let me look at the console
cannot read property start date of
undefined
oh because i i spelled it form date
okay form data
uh and then let me do
start date and then what is that an
object
and end date
i don't know it'll be modeled there okay
cool and so now i have my start date and
my end date awesome
submit and reset of course i don't have
those hooked up to anything
so yeah i have like 30 seconds left
um except for afcc
guest spots yeah exactly so all my other
coding streams are on my twitch account
i have live interviews
on this account so like uh danny
thompson he came on my channel the other
day
maybe you've seen him if you're around
coding twitter and instagram
he's a really great uh speaker coder
all that stuff you can check in your
view dev tools
yes i will use view dev tools in the
next stream
oh wait this is awesome this is awesome
i can finally zoom in and view devtools
in a stream yeah i'll definitely be
using that next time
firefox has been slightly frustrating
i mean just i mean not being able to
zoom in anyway
so what do you guys think about the
project it's it's kind of cool right
uh i have all the different pages
stuff is starting to get set up the
components are there
the plugins a little bit of the design
is there
thanks anish yeah this stream felt
um a lot more like a real project than
the other streams
before i was just kind of building the
free code camp projects
which was also kind of cool because i
built them five years ago
and then to go back and build them in a
new framework today
that was that was cool for me anyway
yeah thanks jared thanks anish thanks
tom uh
thanks sashi thanks everyone for
everyone who joined the stream
chatted i know a lot of people couldn't
chat which is unfortunate but
if you want to chat then um
join my discord channel
so after this stream i'm going to post a
comment on the stream with a link to my
discord channel
so you can chat with me further let me
know what you thought about the project
and feel free to go to the github
the github for this project and raise an
issue i have to get off the stream now
but i'm about to push the code
yes i need to i'm going to push the code
and i'm going to rearrange
the png mess that i made here and update
it
so that's gonna be live in the next five
minutes
okay so i'll do that as soon as i get
off
thanks again for coming check out my
youtube channel and i look forward to
seeing you again for this project
next friday morning take care